walker bueller's seven shoutout innings
his last time against the pirates on
tuesday and over his last five he's four
and over the 136.
not new but i think improved and i think
walker is maturing before our very eyes
euther comes home and gets a chase for
strike three in the first out of the day
[Music]
another 2-2 and bueller's already got as
many strikeouts as he had tuesday in
pittsburgh
for a little that weak contact get it
over with early
use your defense
solac pulls it on the ground to third
zach mckinstry just his second start of
the season over there makes the play and
even with all the traffic kaziro put up
by bueller in the first
dunning on the mound for the rangers we
talked about him in the open 12 starts
this year
pretty solid numbers for him
coming off a good outing against tampa
up comes gavin lox who had a two for
four night in game one including a homer
luck slashes one to left center field
that's a base hit that'll split the gap
and bounce to the wall injecting energy
immediately driving home bets from first
dodgers one rangers nothing
let the kids play and he came to play
swaps this ball into the left center gap
once it gets to the wall
now dino igo's thinking we got a chance
to score mookie then he sees that and it
is easy not to stop your right arm if
you're a third base coach and you got
this guy running and you've got a bobble
in left field and you need a run early
to get some energy
and that's what happens
2015 the only year that he was an
all-star also hit 20 home runs that year
hit 3 15.
he strikes out here and the inning is
done dunning
allows just the one run leaves a man at
third well that along with the two seam
has been the best pitch for buehler
during this five game run opponents two
for 20 against the slider
on a 2-2 connor falefa watches a
fastball hit the bull's eye for strike
three walker beeler's third k of the
game and he does settle things down with
a 13 pitch second
i said why don't i just take that hit or
hit and run approach into the at-bat
which i wasn't going to use my legs as
much and i probably wasn't going to hit
a home run or
maybe i'm necessarily a double as we
take a look at that strikeout
of luke raleigh if you're dunning you
definitely want the inning to end with
him and have to face bets with the bases
empty next in a 3-2 pitch and that is
strike three called
bueller down looking and the inning is
done
bueller makes quick work of him he
chases 96 up and away
strikeout number four one gone in the
third
two on two out a one-two and he struck
him out
rangers have stranded five over the
first three against bueller it's one
nothing on a gorgeous sunday in l.a so
top of the order here against dane
dunney
backslip swung down the right field line
peeling towards the corner is over it's
gone
inside the foul pole home run milky bats
free advertising for axe handle bats
you chopped it out of here nice
he really did use his top hand very well
there
gets off to the side and doesn't get the
top hand into it there it's probably
going to be weekly hit and slicing foul
that one he stayed on top of and drove
out of here
pop fly into shadow center field on this
bright sunday
it is going to fall
not because they couldn't see it but
because they didn't really communicate
kind of thought garcia was gonna take it
instead it falls and thuds and it's a
base hit
on the first pitch from dunny pollock
wraps one of the ground to third lux is
hung up
holt's coming home
the third goes taylor and lux is out
so two outs made on the bases by the
dodgers in the early innings
oh one pitch runner takes off as
mckinstry serves one in the air to left
center field again
and it'll drive home two
two out two run double zach mckinstry
dodgers four rangers nothing
this is the part of the order that has
given bueller a hard time between gallow
and low they've reached all five times
they've come up
ground ball right side taylor in short
right field
throws him out and finishes off the
fifth we're halfway home in l.a bueller
and the dodgers leading four nothing
right out here
different uniforms
[Applause]
curveball hitting the ground diving stop
locks digs it out to get it to second
in time
that is a very casual call from nick
lens for being that close of a play
oh
the slide did not go directly at the bag
he slides to the inside part of the bag
and doesn't touch the bag until it's his
bare hand
that's the ending
to the bottom of the six we go the
dodgers four the rangers nothing
in terms of his his passion for the game
and how he impacted people or even just
some comedic moments
this one chopped to shortstop backward
flip to second for the one out
he shorts out mckenstry
but raley is on via the fielder's choice
nice play by connor
going hard to his right has to field the
short hop originally he looked like he
was going to go to first base
nice flip across that's a long flip
to solace you always want to get the
lead runner if you can to keep the
double play in order
it was never funny
as pujol strikes out swinging
and the inning is done
dodgers leave another john king two good
scoreless innings so far today
another 2-2 pitch
finishes him off with his slider on the
season opponents against that pitch are
now 2 for 31 with 20 strikeouts
the payoff
over first
there it is a little dump shot base [ __ ]
he's on for the third time
so matt beatty coming up with two out
and bets
at third
baby with a base hit into right center
field in the scores milky bets and it's
five nothing doing his best left-handed
nomar impression fix the batting gloves
get ready back in the box and line drive
only five of them have been strikes the
2-1 pitch and that one on the ground and
through base hit
around third base holt he will score
rangers have them on the corners and
it's a 5-1 game still nobody out
on the ground
through the hole
and that left side it gets another run
to the plate
and it gets martin to third and it's
five to two and the tying run will come
to the plate in the ninth inning
kenley janssen is gonna have to come in
and try and put a stop to this well
things have gotten way too interesting
in this ninth inning from five nothing
to five two two on and nobody out so
here's kenley janssen jansen's first
pitch and this ball hits sharply into
right field that's a base hit
one run is in
the tying runs are now on base
still nobody out
five nothing lead coming into the inning
three runs have scored bases loaded two
out
ground ball to second taylor's there
it was never in doubt
5-3 the final score
[Applause]